quand on dit changer le monde souvent on
a l'impression que c'est meynard me
montagne et que de base le premier mot
qui vient à l'esprit c'est impossible
et moi ça me rend fou il existe plein de
micro engagement aujourd'hui donc des
moyens simples et rapides c'est-à-dire
pour les autres et la planète d'avoir un
impact positif sociale ou écolo par
exemple tu peux utiliser un moteur de
recherche solidaire qui va financer des
associations où planter des arbres et ça
avec l'effet global de millions
d'utilisateurs qui s'en servent
bah ça permet de ramener des millions
d'euros à des associations et de refus
restait par exemple plein de zones
notamment en amazonie
un autre micro engagement c'est de
sauver une vie en 45 minutes
alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est tout
simplement donner son sang est ce que
toi tu donnes ton sang
il savait qu'on peut le donner jusqu'à
quatre à six fois par an par personne
par exemple quelqu'un qui est un
accident de moto qui a perdu beaucoup de
sang ou une femme qui à l'accouchement a
une grosse hémorragie bas ils ont besoin
d'un don du sang est donc toi quand tu
donnes ton sang battue va pouvoir sauver
la vie de cette personne
en tout cas améliorer son traitement et
bah ouais si on fait tout ça ça peut
changer la vie d'un million de patients
qui sont soignés grâce aux dons du sang
par an on en a tous marre de se sentir
impuissant de voir des infos hyper
anxiogène d'avoir l'impression que le
monde il part en cacahuète sans pouvoir
rien faire
ce que je trouve génial avec les micros
également c'est que justement tu passes
de spectateurs à acteurs et que tu
arrêtes d'être un peu victime des
problèmes de société et que tu essaies
de d'agir à ton échelle et surtout de
rejoindre plein d'autres citoyens qui
font bouger les lignes
et bah si on est vachement nombreux bah
ouais ça peut vraiment changer les
choses